[Music]
hey everybody it's charlie this is going
to be my video for all the most powerful
avengers
that can wield stormbreaker i got a lot
of questions about what's going on with
groot because part of him was used to
create the handle
the russo brothers were doing commentary
recently where they revealed what's
going
on with stormbreaker at least what they
intended if it wasn't totally clear from
the events of the movie
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the marvel
videos we're still doing that infinity
war blu-ray giveaway that i'll explain
at the end of the video
so biggest detail first this is the
deciding factor for most of the avengers
who can lift it
is is that there is no worthiness
enchantment on it
so the only two requirements for
wielding stormbreaker
are that you're physically strong enough
to lift it because it's
freaking huge uru metal is incredibly
dense
so you just have to have the muscle to
physically pick it up off the ground
and two this is also really important
you have to be physically resilient
enough to withstand any electrical
discharge
when you're throwing it at people so
when you activate its power or you throw
it at someone there's electrical
discharge
if you're not strong enough you will get
fried that was what that joke thor made
to the guardians was all about
what kind of what kind of weapon are we
talking about here the thanos killing
kind
don't you think that we should all have
a weapon like that no you simply lack
the strength to wield them your bodies
would crumple as your minds collapsed
into madness is it weird that i want to
do it even more now
a little bit shouldn't we all have
thanos killing weapons and he's like
well you could
try but it would melt your brain in your
head as you slowly went insane
the funny thing about that is that there
are actually more than 10 characters
that meet those two requirements so i
just listed the biggest ones on this
starting with number 10 groot he
physically
picked it up to combine and create the
handle so we already know he can lift it
and his body is resilient enough to
handle any electrical discharge
now true it might set him on fire if he
uses it too much
but you have to remember that even
though he's still adolescent groot
groot himself is one of the most
powerful characters in the mcu
number nine of course is the hulk he
could almost lift mjolnir but for the
worthiness enchantment because
stormbreaker doesn't have that he is
physically the strongest avenger
and he can soak pretty much any kind of
energy blast that you throw at him
we haven't seen something that's been
able to overpower him yet but the matter
he gets the stronger he gets so like
when thor
was eating the full power of the star
trying to reactivate it who could do
that too just
fine just to clarify too i'm talking
about hulk being taken down by an energy
blast not by physical blows because
thanos overpowered him physically
looked like he was getting ready to beat
him in the ring during ragnarok but
imagine all this energy coming off of it
as he gets ready to land the killing
blow or try to land the killing blow on
[Music]
thanos
that would just tickle hulk a little bit
like he would barely feel that
number eight captain america because
remember during age of ultron
he was able to budge mjolnir for the
worthiness enchantment
he has the super soldier serum so he's
physically strong enough to lift it and
that also gives him the physical
resilience to eat any kind of energy
discharge that comes off of it when he's
throwing it at people
i'll forgive them for not letting
captain america wield it during infinity
war because there was so much stuff
going on
i think we can all say we'll be a little
salty if they don't pay this off in
avengers 4 where he actually
lifts either mjolnir or stormbreaker
whichever version depending on
which universe version of captain
america you're talking about
seven even though we haven't seen her
yet in avengers 4 she's going to be one
of the most powerful cosmic figures so
obviously captain marvel would be able
to wield it too
even if you've only read a couple of the
comics you have a pretty good sense for
what her power scaling is her binary
ability
kevin feige has been playing hype man
calling her the most powerful
avenger character that they've
introduced not necessarily the most
powerful character overall but most
powerful avenger
number six is iron man there's no
worthiness enchantment so that was the
only thing that stopped him from picking
up mjolnir he was the one during that
age of ultron scene trying to use
science to explain how the worthiness
enchantment worked there is actually a
way to scientifically explain how the
hammer works by manipulating gravitons
and what does iron man's armor do this
was one of the beauties of that first
meeting of those two characters where
they just go at each other
and it supercharges his armor so you
have to imagine that it's the same thing
now in avengers 4. so as long as thor
doesn't throw
stormbreaker iron man he just shoots him
with a blast of lightning he could
actually supercharge him
is also the same thing for captain
marvel that's how her powers work she
can absorb
energy but number five is spider-man
there was that whole explainer that the
russos gave about why
spider-man was the last one to disappear
because he was using his spidey sense
and his
crazy power levels to withstand what was
happening
so even if he's not using his webbing
and physics to lift it
remember the park scene where he flings
part of the car back at cull obsidian
using his webbing
that's him using physics to lift
something that is crazy big but he could
also just pick it up off the ground if
you wanted to as well
so of course number four black panther
is pretty self-explanatory because of
the heart-shaped herb he's about as
powerful
physically as captain america the
vibranium armor that he wears absorbs
kinetic damage but it's also pretty easy
to assume that it could absorb
electrical damage as well as long as
sure he modified it the only thing that
his suit is really weak against are
things that disrupt the connections
between the vibranium nanites that
actually form
the physical armor but even without the
suit he can still soak
some of the energy from the hammer
before it puts him down for the count so
number three
vision obviously he could lift meow near
no problem lifting storm breaker or
absorbing any of the electrical damage
number two scarlet witch is not
physically strong enough but she does
have her telekinesis
so that's the way she wields it and
obviously she could absorb that
electrical damage too
her power isn't necessarily infinite but
it has grown with time so you assume
that if she keeps on living and
developing it she'll get even more
powerful i know people want to see more
from her during phase four
we'll see what happens but for the time
being if she needed to she could pick
the hammer up and throw it at people
telekinetically
same thing with number one doctor
strange he's not physically strong
enough to pick it up but he can use his
magic to wield it and protect himself
from any kind of collateral electrical
damage that it gives off
but like i said there are actually more
than 10 people more than 10 avengers
that can actually pick the hammer up
you have war machine who has all the
same abilities as iron man
ant-man and the wasp could lift it as
long as they were
tiny even loki could wield it nebula and
gamora could probably both wield it
they're physically enhanced so they can
absorb any electrical damage and they're
strong enough to just pick it up off the
ground
winter soldier has all the same
abilities as captain america so he'd be
able to do it too
here's where it gets kind of funny
though the list of people that can't
lift it so
peter quill even though half of his dna
is still celestial he doesn't have his
cosmic powers anymore so he's no
stronger physically than any other human
so like he wouldn't be able to pick it
up off the ground
falcon's suit only gives him the ability
to fly it doesn't make him stronger so
he couldn't pick it up either
neither could hawkeye or black widow so
pretty short list of people that can't
pick it up which is kind of a bummer for
them
but think of it in a my hero academia
way you have to have a quirk in order to
be able to wield the hammer but you can
obtain that quirk a number of ways like
iron man
isn't a meta human he doesn't have super
strength but he has his armor which
gives that to him
where'd that come from it's nanotech you
like it
there was a whole bunch of marvel stuff
that happened recently so i'll try to
get those videos out soon leave all your
requests in the comments below
the blu-ray giveaway is still going on
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video
click here for all those deleted scenes
and click here for more brand new
avengers 4.
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you